en esta ocasión tenemos parte de la
gráfica y es igual a x cuadrada otra vez
la idea en esta ocasión es seguir
trabajando con sólidos de revolución
pero en esta ocasión lo que quiero es
que gire alrededor del eje de las 10 por
lo tanto en lugar de fijarnos en valores
de x me voy a fijar en valores de jeff
voy a decir que quiero el volumen de
este sólido de revolución desde ye igual
a 1 hasta allí igual a 4 y ahora lo que
quiero hacer es girar esta función en
este intervalo alrededor del eje de las
10 es decir no voy a girar de esta
manera y bueno recuerda que lo
importante es que lo podamos visualizar
por lo tanto voy a intentar dibujarlo
para que me quede mucho más concreto
entonces voy a tomar esta de aquí este
de aquí va a ser su base la base de mi
nuevo sólido de revolución esta parte de
acá arriba también va a tener que tener
un corte va a ser esta cara que yo tengo
aquí entonces lo estoy dibujando no me
quedó nada mal y del otro lado también
tengo esta pared ahora lo que voy a
hacer es darle un poquito de grosor
agarre una mejor perspectiva entonces
mira como lo coloreo y ya se ve más un
sólido es más para que se vea mucho
mejor lo voy a dibujar por separado así
vas a entender mejor qué es lo que estoy
haciendo esta es una de las caras aquí
va mi sólido de revolución y después
baja un poco y encuentra a otra de mis
caras a otra de sus bases fíjate que
este volumen se me hace muy parecido
como a un plato para comer serial o algo
así y bueno parece estar muy plano así
que déjenme darle un poco de grosor lo
voy a poner con otro color así y nada
mejor con el color amarillo que teníamos
en un principio le voy a dar grosor y es
que recuerda que lo importante es que
podamos visualizar estos sólidos de
revolución eso me sirve bastante para
encontrar la solución y muchas veces
visualizar este tipo de problemas es la
parte difícil es como un medio tazón
algo como un trofeo así que vamos a
dibujar también los ejes para guiarnos
un poco más este va a ser el eje de las
10 y después se intersecta este eje con
el eje de las x
y bueno lo que estoy intentando es que
tengas otra perspectiva para que lo
puedas visualizar mejor y entiendas
mejor qué es lo que está pasando no sea
tan difícil esta etapa que yo tengo aquí
es esta etapa que estoy dibujando acá y
ahora la pregunta va a ser como
encuentro yo el volumen de este sólido
de revolución que me acabo de plantear
ahora la idea que hay detrás es más o
menos la misma que hice en el vídeo
anterior me voy a tomar discos pero en
esta ocasión en lugar de tomar médicos
alrededor del eje de las x me voy a
tomar discos alrededor del eje de las 10
y es que piensan un poco realmente la
lógica suena bien y entonces tomamos un
cierto valor de james y a partir de aquí
voy a crear un disco así que tengo un
radio igual al valor de esa función y
bueno aquí tengo la cara de mi disco
después necesito un cierto grosor y
recuerda que estamos hablando de discos
muy muy delgados por eso estoy dibujando
un disco delgado y bueno este disco no
va a tener un grosor de de x como en el
vídeo pasado mejor vamos a decir que
tiene un grosor de d
ahora lo que sería bueno preguntarnos
pues va a ser cuál es el volumen de este
disco pero en términos de y así que lo
que necesitamos es el área de la base o
de la cara de esta moneda de este disco
y bueno como también es una
circunferencia entonces vamos a decir
que es pi por radio al cuadrado pero
ahora la pregunta es cuál es el radio
bueno como queremos todo en términos de
i pues entonces lo que necesitamos es de
esta expresión despejar ay es decir en
este caso lo que voy a tomarme es la
raíz cuadrada de ambos lados y por lo
tanto me va a quedar que la raíz
cuadrada de james es igual a equis y
bueno ya que tenemos este despeje sería
muy bueno saber si es congruente pero si
es congruente porque ya siempre es
positiva recuerda que no hay raíces de
números negativos y lo bueno es que
estamos en el eje positivo de las guías
y bueno ya con esto entonces podemos
decir que x es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de james y vamos a fijarnos solamente en
la parte derecha de esta función que al
final es justo lo que queríamos girar
entonces no hay tanto problema estamos
bien en todo y perfecto sí ya estoy
expresando esta función como una función
que depende de iu entonces cuál va a ser
el radio que yo necesito pues claro el
radio va a ser igual a la raíz de jeff
el radio nuestro radio va a ser igual a
la raíz cuadrada de james y bueno no
quiero confundirte porque casi siempre
nosotros tomamos una función de x pero
en este caso pues va a ser una función
de ella y es más vamos a llamarla no sé
en lugar de f
llamémosla g de james ahora sí vamos a
sacar el área el área es igual a pipo
del cuadrado entonces esto quiere decir
que el área es igual a pi por el radio
al cuadrado pero quien es el radio el
radio es la raíz de y exactamente y
bueno el área o más bien esto va a ser
igual a pi por el radio elevado al
cuadrado que es la raíz del elevado al
cuadrado que es
y ahora es lo que nosotros queremos es
el volumen de este disco pues hay que
multiplicar esta área por d por el
grosor así que el volumen de cada uno de
estos discos va a ser igual a pi que
multiplica y que multiplica a day en
esto de aquí es el volumen de nuestros
discos del disco del disco de la moneda
ahora si lo que nosotros queremos es el
volumen de este tazón entero entonces lo
que hay que hacer es tomar la suma de
todos los volúmenes de cada uno de los
discos de cada uno de los discos desde
ya igual a uno hasta igual a cuatro por
lo tanto me voy a tomar la integral la
integral de uno hasta cuatro y bueno no
se te olvide que al tomar la integral
estoy tomando una suma muy especial es
la suma de todos estos discos pero
además lo que estoy haciendo es una suma
infinita porque lo que estoy diciendo es
que de ye se está volviendo muy pero muy
pero muy pequeño y por lo tanto voy a
tener la cantidad mayor y mayor y mayor
de discos y bueno esto quiere decir que
lo que estoy haciendo es tomar una
aproximación al volumen de este tazón y
más aún en él
es el volumen de este tazón y bueno si
esta es la fórmula del volumen entonces
habrá que resolver esta integral para
saber cuánto es el volumen sacamos la
constante que es pi y nos queda una
integral que no sabemos de memoria esto
es lo mismo que ye cuadrada entre 2
evaluado de 14 y bueno esto es igual a
pi que multiplica a 4 elevado al
cuadrado entre 2 menos uno elevado al
cuadrado entre 2 esto aplicando los
límites de evaluación y esto es lo mismo
que pi que multiplica a 16 entre 2 que
es 8 menos 1 al cuadrado entre 2 que es
un medio y bueno aquí tengo 16 medios
menos un medio pues es lo mismo que 15
medios y x
me quedan 15 pi medios o lo que es lo
mismo 15 medios de pi y lo hemos logrado
perfecto porque ya encontramos por fin
el volumen de este sólido de revolución
pero esta vez no giraba alrededor del
eje de las equis giraban alrededor del
eje de las 10 este fue un ejercicio
emocionante no creen